[Music]
i'm going to play a
b3 an imazovic larson in dr lona's honor
e5
should be two
knight c6 okay so
this is the first moment when there are
there are several
possible variations
uh today i'm going to play this
traditionally so does anybody know what
the traditional main line is in this
position what is white supposed to do
yeah so the move is e3
and as with all hyper modern openings
the point of this opening is not to
control the center with pawns it's to
get your pieces out
and put immediate pressure on black
center so that is we got this bishop out
to b2 where does this bishop belong well
that is a very obvious question
with an obvious answer which is b5
we want to attack the knight which is
defending the pawn
and depending on how black and black can
get in big trouble here really quickly
if he is not super careful because you
could end up just losing a pawn here
bishop d6
now
this is a pretty famous line
which again could end very badly for
black
what we have to notice about this move
is that it opens up
a potential x-ray on that g7 pawn if we
capture it with the bishop
hypothetically that means if the e pawn
moves or it disappears
we will potentially win a lot of
material by taking a g7
so the move knight f3 looks really good
it looks really natural but black can
actually play f6
and create a pawn chain that will make
the e5 pawn very hard to pressure
further
so we have to use our pawns here we have
to go after i'm sure this is a move a
lot of you are familiar with
this idea occurs in many different
openings that involve a fianchetto
we attack the pawn with our pawn putting
more immediate pressure than a knight
would
okay
so
black has
a pretty unenviable choice here
if he takes i believe this line is just
bad for black after bishop takes g7 he
does have a check on h4
uh but it's not scary we just move our
king there and i don't think black has
any initiative
um
the move f6 i believe is
considered
far better but it still doesn't solve
all of black's problems we can trade
once we open the f file and then knight
f3 becomes a lot stronger
well i'm explaining the logic behind f4
right you should unders even if you're a
beginner you should fully understand
this move
you're pushing out the pawn it's
untouchable
and pawns
are the best way to pressure other pawns
yeah queen e7 is also possible but then
we play knight f3 gives a check on h4
which obviously we need to block with a
move g3 thank you there we go i think
you're happy cabera
happy
i really appreciate it queen e7 i think
this is the best line actually for white
okay so what do we do now
do we want to take the spawn is that
premature
well it's definitely premature to take
that defeats the whole purpose of what
we're doing here which is to put
pressure on the pawn by trading it
uh we are giving black get out of jail
free card
so obviously here we would just develop
knight f3
continuing to pressure the pawn
okay bishop g4 good move
now
i think that
there's a couple of ways to approach
this position
um
but we need to do some calculation here
so
what are the options the first option is
to deal
with the immediate problem of this pin
which is very annoying we cannot castle
we shouldn't castle because e4 becomes a
possible potential problem even if black
gives up g7 we don't want to give this
knight away
so we can play the move h3 here
which essentially forces the bishop to
capture the knight because he would get
trapped if he went to h5
the downside of that is that the knight
was pressuring the e5 pawn it's perhaps
not ideal for us to trade it
um
what is the second option here what else
can we do
no we can't go d3 because he still goes
e4
bishop e2 is way too passive i wouldn't
move this bishop away it's pressuring
the knight
so the the other move is f takes e5 now
i hear you thinking didn't you just say
this was a bad move well the situation
has changed it was a bad move here
because black would be able to take with
the bishop
and take the sting out of our bishop
here
it's a lot more complicated because
after f takes e5 bishop takes c5
we play bishop takes e5
and he's unable to recapture with the
knight
so
this is this carries a lot more weight
now that the knight is on f3 than
previously
right so again just because a move is
bad in one position you know that you
know the spiel doesn't mean it's bad in
another
and important captures you have to
evaluate and reevaluate on every move
because the circumstances may have
changed
now what should black do
after bishop take c5 bishop takes e5
we'll see if he finds this how should
black actually proceed here
and he can make this move immediately in
this position but it would be a grave
mistake
actually maybe it wouldn't be oh it's
interesting
bishop takes knight yeah so after takes
takes he should take the knight with a
bishop
we have to respond to that by taking the
bishop and then the queen is able to
take that bishop but we have forced him
to give away his strongest peace so i
still believe that white will be
slightly better there but that's totally
what he should do this is the only move
for black
okay so hopefully i'm explaining things
clearly for now
let's see what black does
[Music]
okay bishop f3 immediately
now this is really interesting
um
one of the most important things not to
do in chess is assume
that two different move orders lead to
the same conclusion
when you have calculated something your
opponent makes a different first move
you always have to ask yourself
does this give me any other options and
even if the answer is no it's worth
thinking about for a little bit
and if you think about that for a little
bit you'll see that it in fact does in
this position you don't have to take
this bishop
you can take the other bishop
not only attacking the queen
but most importantly opening up the
pressure on g7 so let's calculate pawn
takes bishop
bishop takes queen
pawn takes queen and it's in fact a
double attack we are attacking number
one the bishop on d1 number two we are
threatening that old idea bishop takes
g7
so it's easy
now i i left something out
black has an additional move here let's
see if he finds it what should black try
here who sees it
do not assume that you have to capture
the queen you got to look around
queen f6 is not possible because there's
a bishop there
queen e4 we need four would be the most
testing response and in fact may seem
that white is now losing after queen e4
because black forks the queen and the
rook
but that's where things kind of get
tactical and complicated so we're going
to wait to see what black does and if he
goes queen e4 then we're going to start
thinking
i do see a response to queenie 4 but i
have to walk you through the logic
thank you chris link
well it's not too crazy this is very
easy to keep track of right both queens
are hanging and the bishop is hanging so
if he takes the pawn we take the bishop
if he takes the queen we take his queen
the other thing that's hanging is the g7
pawn it's good in your mind just to keep
a little tab open of everything that's
hanging just so you don't forget to
capture something if you get the
opportunity we need four found
now
situations like these
there are two main approaches i mean the
first is to move our queen we can go
queen c1 but i don't like that he takes
the rook
and even though we technically could
take on g7 and recover the rook i i'm
really afraid for our king in that
position
remember if he captures the rook we
won't be able to castle short
now a lot of you are coming up with the
correct general idea what if we counter
attack his queen that queen 94 looks
awfully vulnerable
okay so what about the move pawn to d3
well pawn moves weak in other pawns and
pawn to d3 gets checkmated queen takes
e3
not good
well we could try the move bishop d3 but
as i said if possible i don't want to
move that bishop away from b5 that's an
important bishop are there any other
pieces which could attack black's queen
well look around the board there is very
nice guys knight c3 is i think
a very important resource
again we are counter-attacking black's
queen it's easy to establish this line
bishop takes d1 knight takes e4
the bishop is hanging the knight is
hanging and the pawn on g7 is also
hanging so we don't even have to
recapture the bishop there we can take
on g7 we'll be up in exchange at the end
of the line
that's a nice move but it's it's not so
difficult to find if you know what to
look for
yeah we could play d7 in between move
but i'm not sure ruining castling is
worth giving up this pawn over
because if we get into some end game you
might envision a situation where g7 is
hanging and the pawn actually threatens
to capture c7 if that makes sense
if the queens are traded we will we will
regret having played d7 and bringing
black skin closer to the center
bishop d3 i don't believe is a better
move but maybe it is i don't know maybe
you check to the computer
bishop takes d1
knight takes c4 and i think we're
winning
he takes e4 now
what should we do
should we take the bishop and i already
hinted at this
well this is a matter of understanding
what the options are
clearly we should play bishop to hg7
although taking the bishop would have
been amazing too i mean we would have
been two pawns up there with two amazing
bishops but
we can win the exchange here
because black will not be able to get
anything for that rook
black will not be able to get anything
for that rock
the best thing that he can do is go
bishop f3
we can move the rook
and then we take on h
well bishop takes c2 is not scary it's
just a pawn we play bishop takes h8
bishop f3 now what would be the best
move here who sees kind of a sexy
way to meet such a move
to clarify the rules
and first i'll let people find the move
yeah it's actually the castle so
castling is legal when the rook is
attacked it's just illegal when there's
a check
do not forget about that very often
people just assume that they can't
castle here because the rook's attacked
but that's not true you can castle and
in fact you should
because this coordinates the rooks
the king is very very safe here
for all of eternity
yeah so learning new things every day
that's why you should sub to this
channel
just kidding
i would never
f6
okay so this is
let's take the rook
um this is the best attempt i think the
black has he is trying to trap our
bishop
um i don't think that black is gonna be
successful but in order to extricate it
we need to
we need to be creative
all right
so
first things first
i think we have a good check here
i think that the bishop has done its job
and um i think we should begin by giving
this check
and creating pressure against the knight
that's not going to hurt i think this
move is just a helpful move i don't know
how we're going to follow it up yet but
let's start with that check
now the king's probably going to go to
g6 if it goes back
then it would sever the connection of
the rook and the bishop
now
what really helps in such positions is
first to ask yourself what is black's
next move going to be
what is
black's next move going to be here
well it's going to be knight h6 it's not
going to be 97 because there's a pawn on
d6
so
what is the drawback of the move knight
h6
is there anything that you notice
let's imagine for a second that black
it's black to move and he plays knight
h6
what should we do in that position how
does black get the most for the for the
bishop like if we're already losing our
bishop we might as well give it up for a
pawn right
um
and there is a way to do that we can
take that pawn on f6 i think all of you
guys see that
now let's say it's black to move in this
hypothetical universe knight h6 bishop
takes f6 king takes f6
well what do we notice about that
resulting position
well if you look carefully you'll see
that there's a rook and it's skewering
sorry it's pinning the bishop on f3 that
pin however does not seem effective
why because there's a pawn on e4 that's
guarding the bishop
and our pawns are too far advanced to
attack that bishop so that bishop seems
entirely safe but pawns can be
can be dismantled and so
according to that logic the best move
here would be d3
play d3 in order after knight h6 bishop
takes f6 king takes f6
to have the move d takes e4 and the
bishop is lost
yeah bishop d5 might have been even
better
i i completely missed that move to be
honest with you i completely missed
bishop d5
but this is not such a long line i'm
walking you through the logic i saw d3
very quickly because
i saw the idea of taking on f6
immediately
and the move d3 follows logically from
that because you got to dismantle the
defender of the bishop if you're going
to try to win it
okay but i don't like the phrase i never
would have thought of that this is
contrary to my
my point my basic speed run
understanding okay actually he's
doing something really smart
or not wait no we have a move here okay
so what did we do now we've we've
succeeded in getting that bishop out of
f3 we need to pounce on our opportunity
yeah we take the knight this is easy
take the knight take the pawn we've
extricated our bishop we're up in
exchange and the game is essentially
over
so the phrase i never would have thought
of that that's why i try to spell out
the exact logic
to show you that
maybe if you beef up your understanding
that one day you'll be able to come up
with these ideas they're not
as impossible as they seem
so this is winning
this is winning
[Music]
chess is a logical game at most
sort of
levels of understanding
and he resigns yeah this position is
resignable it's not in exchange
okay i will because i was explaining
things in a lot of depth i will take
questions but i won't like
fully recap everything so first question
cesar asks was bishop f3 a viable
response thank you ola kim
after you took the queen with the
knights
he would have forked your rook at night
and i think the knight was undefended
yes so your it would have been a viable
defense
but it was very likely to transpose into
the game so one thing i could do here
probably not the best thing
but i could even castle in this position
and if he takes the knight you will
notice that this is the exact same
position as in the game
so it doesn't really matter
whether he takes the knight first it
drops the bishop back first because
we're not taking the bishop anyway we
were taking the pawn
i guess bishop f3 gives white less of a
choice
but that's the end whoa
tons of subs deutsch blitz of the prime
bloomington pilot with a prime thank you
let's get this party started
could can you walk through bishop d4
over d3 oh yeah bishop d5 you mean
couldn't he just move the queen instead
of going to the queen trade so that's a
great question
where could this queen go there are only
two squares from which the queen
actually maintains its defense of the
bishop the first is queen f5
what should be white's response to queen
f5
what should we do here
and if you saw if you solve your tactics
you'll see this move it's you have to
notice that any two pieces that are
aligned on the same file
castles
is the best or rook f1 but as we've
discussed it's better to castle
boom it's over we are skewering and
winning everything
what is the other move the other move is
queen g4 what should we do here and i
think queen g4 would have been the best
move relatively speaking but it doesn't
solve all of black's problems
here we go bishop b2 because now the
queen is in the same diagonal as the
bishop
after bishop takes c2 queen takes c2
queen takes e2 check who can tell me
what we should take the queen with and
there's a very famous game
on this topic that i could show you guys
um we should of course take with the
knight
in general in the end game taking with
the king is a good idea because you
bring it closer to the center but here
you have to forget to remember that the
pawn on g7 is hanging
so by taking with the knight we are
creating a double threat of taking on c7
and taking on g7 we're going to be up a
pawn in the end black is going to win
back
that uh pawn on um
sorry let me remember this game
it's a very short game
it's not petrosian re i'm trying to
remember
this game
which featured a very similar idea
oh yeah this one resurvive against
kubray trick that's the famous one
okay
all right so both of these are very very
strong soviet players they're playing
under 18.
in croatia um no not great i don't know
where duke is
so at this point they're both very very
strong and there have been several games
which have gone exactly in this way so
it's an english c45
black plays the move f5 which is still
very popular d4 e4 bishop g5
um
knight f6
and here uh white initiates this
interesting idea why plays d5 but i know
you guys have seen this kind of idea
before your counter attack last night
okay e takes
f3 right d takes c6
and f takes g2
in this position
white can take back on g2 but then y
will end up upon down so the typical
reaction here is to take on d7 with
check
and after bishop takes d7 bishop takes
you through the position is very unclear
what
did white
miss
what did white miss
you have to think outside the box here
it's not king e7 come on
well queen takes spawn is not so
impressive queen takes spawn i take the
queen and then i take on g2 and we get
an end game so queen dick spawn is
possible but it's not so impressive
the move is knight takes d7 and white
resigned
uh because white loses at least a piece
this is a brilliant move remember that
this pawn is threatening to take the
rook and make a new queen
so white has to take it but then white
loses on g5 and a couple of very strong
players lost in exactly this way this is
not the only game from this position
so just remember the idea of like
basically making a second threat with a
capture
um it's a good idea to just like file
away into your
mental database
yeah knight takes d7 and the game is
over
okay so you can kind of see the
similarity we take on e2 we create
another threat and therefore we
guarantee that we're able to take c7
okay
so
we have spelled out both possible queen
retreats
and what we would have done against them
and this is just game over
now queen takes e3 will lose a piece
though this is a desperado but you only
win a pawn
and you lose the bishop
all right guys i think
i've basically covered most of people's
questions about this game
um
i will call it a night here it's been a
pretty long stream four hours plus
so
again i want to thank everybody for the
subs it really really helps
for the awesome support we had some
great matches acaro
tons of other players so i'm really
happy at the chest today
[Music]
you